hey guys how's it going it's justine and
today we're in my kitchen and i have a
very very special guest
this is the one the only iphone doe
hello so thanks so much for coming thank
you for having me we had quite the
adventure this morning so we both
ordered flame throwers and then what did
we what did we do this morning
well we went to pick it up because they
said that we were gonna
have they go they were gonna have this
party and then we were gonna able to
play with the flamethrower
and pick up our own flamethrower well we
picked it up they also had a little demo
thing a lot of things happened
here's a quick little vlog clip of it
capri sun
and churros
okay so we just had like a really really
bad experience like nothing was working
and then they like kicked us out and
said sorry
only one per person i'm like but it
didn't actually work
you're not the only one no you're like
everybody's having problems we did that
one over there and it was great
i was so sad well lee sures worked yeah
that's good so it didn't quite work out
as well as i had planned but it's okay
because now we're here we have it in my
house and guess what
we're gonna do an unboxing i should
probably get an unboxing knife
okay i made spaghetti with this the
other day
do you think this is please tell me to
watch forza fire
no what's the reference i don't i don't
watch many things
this will cut i'm sorry
if you know what i'm talking about let
me know i'm only laughing because i
don't get the reference but it does cut
so we've got some instructions here this
is a manual that came with it
it is actually not a flamethrower
usually i don't read directions but i
feel like maybe we should
maybe for this one yeah
helpful there's a lot of things in here
like this so here's everything that is
on it
we've got the nozzle the ignition switch
the trigger the regulator the propane
tank
the idle valve and the fuel bracket this
is not a flamethrower
it is not why not for legal reasons
in all of the emails it's like our
lawyers made us say this which makes
sense because this thing is
pretty intense purchasing propane
mounting propane
troubleshooting let's open i don't think
i need this
no but you know
[Laughter]
whoa not a flamethrower
[Music]
what do you think i think it's pretty
impressive
what did you think when you bought this
i thought it was going to be more
like a decorative like hahaha yes
there's this little fire coming out
and when i saw what it can do during the
pickup event
i was pretty amazed and a little
worried maybe a lot of people bought it
what my house is definitely catching on
fire today
do you want to help me with the other
side yes this is really heavy yes it is
oh there we go wow
so first we've got um oh look here's the
serial number
i am one three four seven
why was i not 1-3-3-7 we should have
requested it
let's take this out of here
it's heavier than i remember that's it
that's it
nothing else that's exciting
so it uses a standard 14.1 ounce propane
tank
attach the propane tank okay let's do it
i just what's the worst that can happen
i mean honestly
do we have a fire extinguisher handy oh
yeah one second
i mean that flame that we saw earlier
was aggressive but they said that it was
potentially because of the wind
are you going to go for it or plan
um what's the expiration date on that
this is the baking
does this do they expire oh yeah really
i think it's fine it's fine fire
extinguisher is handy
in the back and now we're just gonna do
this take this off of here
jam this in here who sold me this are
they crazy
as far as i've seen it it doesn't last
long i'm gonna have to postmate some
propane
oh i almost got your finger no no okay
so there's little arrows that say on off
when we were at the demo they said rit
was something that we needed to remember
regulator ignite and then trigger please
don't point it towards the light if the
diffusion hits it'll just go right
so and if that happens
you need to be you got to stay you got
to get the shot we put the fire out you
have to
you have to keep filming of course
this seems to be all screwed in is there
anything else i should know i don't
think so i think this is like a very
simple thing
and i'm over complicating like usual
what did we agree on
did we sign our lives away uh i will not
use this in a household okay wait really
yeah
does it say i want you i will not point
this at my spouse i will not use this in
an unsafe way
oh we're using it very safe yeah we're
safe we're being safe we have
a virus totally controlled environment
yeah
yeah what if we go outside and do the
first one outside yeah test to see where
it's gonna come yeah
and then okay we're gonna test this
outside first because
now i got nervous and then we'll come
back
good night
wow jeez oh god
wow wow yeah it doesn't seem like
it's very as soon as i turn so it starts
coming out from there that's weird
[Music]
the trigger is automatically like
oh my goodness flaming
this is ridiculous now i see why they
tell you not to use this in a house
that's not an option okay
well it worked it's unboxed
stay tuned for a cooking video because
i'm gonna try to cook with a
flamethrower and i was gonna shoot this
in my kitchen but there's absolutely no
way we can do that
that's the oh my gosh
you're good yes
we do this so we don't burn each other
if i stand here yeah maybe because like
i don't
this is super dangerous how's that is
that far enough do you think
yes okay yeah cause i don't okay
so we're gonna try to just do this
okay so propane on
ignite i didn't even hit the trigger
that's what i was telling you
i'm so happy
somebody
oh wow
all right let's turn it off off
the things that have happened in this
backyard
so we're back inside now and i'm really
glad you said that we probably should
try this outside first
yeah me too i'm really glad i'm really
glad we didn't do it inside one things
i'm surprised is
this was 500 this was like not a cheap
thing and i thought it was going to be a
little
more like a little more quality for a
500
flamethrower that's not actually a
flamethrower with all that being said
it's really freaking cool it looks super
cool it looks amazing
yeah do not use this indoors do not
no read the read the terms they're not
joking
even though it's written in a joking
manner it's pretty serious
it is quite serious well guys thank you
for watching i'm gonna try to do
a little cooking video we've got some
fun things that we're gonna try to cook
with the flame thrower also be sure to
check out his channel i'll put links in
the description
to all of your wonderful social media
i'm such a big fan so thank you so much
i'm such a big fan of myself we're both
big fans of each other so this works out
perfectly great
we'll see you guys in the next video wow
this is crazy
i still can't believe i didn't get one
through three seven close
okay so we're gonna go to the hardware
store
we've got we're gonna bring our manuals
with us
we should probably actually buy a couple
fire extinguishers while we're there
to be honest yeah because we have a
fever
and the only prescription is
more flame throwing i was like is it
more cowbell or
all right let's hop in the car we are on
our way to the hardware store
to get ourselves some more propane
to burn some fire yeah we gotta we gotta
cook i've got
so many random pieces of meat
and s'mores oh oh we need to get one of
those like metal rod things
yes that they had at the event so we can
like just put stuff on that and just
burn it
the roof the roof is on fire
the roof the roof the roof is on fire
we don't need no water let the mother
[Music]
burn
[Music]
well hopefully it'll be quick we just
gotta get this propane tank
welcome to the hardware store
soap oh i need some soap we have some
propane here but these are
too big flame friendly ceramic grilling
pan
this is what we need we need this flame
friendly i think we need a cart
i think we what has happened
there's a grilled cheese basket
you can't take me anywhere look at this
yes
we need that and what we need to do is
for example i will hold it like this no
and you
no oh yeah okay this is a nice bucket
it's a cool bathroom look at this little
chicken
on the stand we might have to stop at
the grocery store to get a whole chicken
like that
oh yeah this video is exponentially
getting either better or worse
if i was a little propane tank where
would i be
do you know if you have a 14.1 ounce
propane tank
that would be maybe be back with you
guys in a moment
14.1 ounce propane tank
14.1 there's all kinds of stuff that i
see that i probably should have in my
house like an adult would but i don't
oh pink tape wow that's really pretty
it has to be he said it would be up here
by torches
but we don't need no water let the
mother
burn that's cool i could jam some meat
on that
oh those are actual rods yeah
oh wow wow well should we get this one
though because like if we
slam a steak on this okay this might be
a little more
all right substantial okay do you know
if you have a 14.1 ounce propane tank
oh my gosh i've walked past here four
times down low
thank you we just got a flamethrower
we've got a lot of meat to cook oh
should i get a hat
there's a chicken he's 80 dollars one of
the hats made down here
from there oh no he
blew away i see something else that we
might need
this could actually be even better we
hang the meat off of here
that is true that could actually be
better oh this one's on sale
and i could use these again and put like
flower pots on them all right let's see
what else we can see because this place
is fantastic i'm seeing so much stuff i
still want to get the sand
do you go to hardware stores often no me
either
no i i'm just just like you i'm
usually at home i'm enjoying this
going outside it is really nice it's
very different i didn't know
do you hear the birds chirping yeah it's
beautiful
look at these i'm not i'm not even
acting like this is real do you guys
have sand yes
way in the back oh okay i went uh i
don't think that's the type of sand that
i'm thinking
i want like nice sand that if i had a
sandbox
that's what i would put in it that's
like construction
oh it's over here
i'm over here i'm just you guys try that
login should we look again
but it said it had jointer sand is that
what we want what's the difference
between jointer sand
and all-purpose sand it's all it's kind
of like all-purpose flour
right i think that's just for joiners
what does that mean
what what's that mean joyner like drugs
wow sandwich heavy
chunks this wasn't this reminds me
this is not what i remember as a kid
well my dad would get us like santa
to put in a sandbox this is like
freaking
heavy look at this it's shocking i think
we have everything
we have everything and more yeah you got
next time oh cause we're gonna get nuts
this is crazy oh my gosh we can't
actually eat the things that we cook
let's go to the beach beach maybe i'll
start a garden
may i get this no
this is the budget for the video when
will i get to say like i bought propane
for
just me
no no you just tricked me
i
trickery trick or trickery but tell me
like there's
no other event that where i get to say
hey i bought propane too
just
[Music]
we'll try it's the sand it's throwing us
off
let's go let's go
well i'm definitely not going to sleep
tonight because i'm going to be editing
yeah right like what like what is this
it's going to work it's gonna be great
thank you of course wowie
is it on fire
mine's still on
[Music]
you